pt le problème c'est que je ne suis pas
plus sévère avec le public de cette
émission avec mes enfants et on voit
bien on voit bien que je les tiens pas
du tout quoi bon alors votre bouquin
très intéressant fait beaucoup de bruit
vous montrer que oussama ben laden n'est
que officiellement en rupture avec
l'arabie saoudite
êtes-vous dit en parlant de ben laden
qu'il en incarne plus la face cachée
serait ça fait à peu près de 30 ans que
l'arabie saoudite cache son jeu et je
dirais qu'on ferme les yeux en même
temps sur sur cette face cachée de
l'arabie saoudite qui qui se pense au
rize qui financent par son establishment
je dirais financier bancaire le
fondamentalisme et en particulier ben
laden de plessisville des années 80
alors si vous fait marrer vous c'est
l'histoire des demi-frères vendredi ben
laden il a déjà mis frère celui dans un
pays où il ya la polygamie et guillaume
dans un pays où il ya la polygamie ne
doit pas y avoir de demi frère oui c'est
vrai qu'un arabie saoudite
quand un homme comme sheikh mohammed bin
laden le père d'oksana plusieurs à cinq
ans deux enfants avec plusieurs femmes
c'est une tribu c'est un clan et
naturellement on n'est pas demi frère en
est membre du même clan pareil il faut
comprendre avec la psychologie la
signification de là-bas pour vous-même
laden ceni un fou ni un traître
par rapport à l'arabie saoudite ont dit
on le dit d'ailleurs c'est le produit de
son pays produit à la fois religieux
bien sûr le fondamentalisme et puis le
produit financier ben laden c'est un
homme d'affaires un homme d'affaires qui
a bien réussi qu'il négociait au début
des années 80 qui a été désigné par le
patron des services de renseignement
saoudiens comme représentant de l'arabie
saoudite 1 en afghanistan pour aller sur
le front pour recruter des combattants
et puis plus tard a pu à partir de là
gagny de l'arabie saoudite faire ses
affaires toujours mais à ce moment là
dedans un dessin terroristes bien sûr
alors votre livre c'est la première
tentative d'explication disons cohérente
de ce qui s'est passé parce que jusque
là on a vu des choses on n'a pas très
bien compris ce qui se passait pour vous
tout s'explique par le contrôle des
matières premières à commencer bien
entendu par le pétrole
aujourd'hui en dehors du golfe persique
les principales réserves sont en asie
centrale
et oui c'est vrai que le kazakhstan a
été surnommé assez tôt et parler les
compagnies pétrolières américaines
the new koweit le nouveau web enfin ça
en dit long j'espère que nos amis
téléspectateurs donc il ya évidemment le
golfe persique qui produit du pétrole il
ya un deuxième endroit où il ya beaucoup
de pétrole
c'est l'asie centrale pour acheminer ce
pétrole d'asie centrale vers la mer pour
le venir le prendre avec des tanks
heures effectivement il faut faire un
pipe line d'un pipeline un gazoduc à un
oléoduc voilà à leers et organiste ans
d'où l'importance de l'afghanistan en
comprendre pourquoi ce pays
contrairement aux pays dont vous parliez
d'un larry lévy dont on parle pas je
suis là intéresse les gens parce que
c'est celui par roux doit transiter le
pétrole qui vient d'asie centrale
et alors l'arabie saoudite et les usa il
ya une espèce de concurrence comme ça
pour contrôler l'afghanistan oui si vous
voulez le pétrole nous aveugle en
afghanistan est effectivement l'occident
a besoin d'un régime for marriage in
italy banques et donc qui est en place
elle s'en accommode
et effectivement elle ferme les yeux sur
la tyrannie de ce régime et puis elle
nous aveugle également en arabie
saoudite puis ce qu'on ferme les yeux
sur le soutien qu'apporte
l'establishment l'arabie saoudite aux
terroristes c'est très clair alors donc
les américains quand bush a été élu avec
le soutien du lobby pétrolier
oui je vais vous expliquer tout ça a dit
que chesnais kendira essai puis d'autres
viennent des sociétés pétrolières sont
des gens qui travaillaient dans le
pétrole et on sait bien que bush était
élu à l'aide de ce lobby pétrolier est
pile cc public oui oui alors il entame
des négociations dès qu'ils arrivent
contrairement à kinshasa les arrêter il
entame des négociations avec les
talibans
oui disent voulu livrer ben laden
vous participez les talibans vous nous
livrez ben laden nous participer à un
gouvernement élargi
qu'on discute au cours d'une loya jirga
avec toute l'assemblée du peuple afghan
et puis au dessus de 100 mais le roi
zahir shah voilà donc les américains
sont en train de pierre vous ai donc
fait du pognon quoi les américains ont
commencé par négocier avec les talibans
suis pas seule chose qu'ils voulaient
c'est ben laden qui avait commis des
attentats contre le le bateau est au sss
choléra ont dit aux talibans rendez-nous
une partie de votre pouvoir on va y
mettre
ailleurs shanghai hirsch avec qui on
discute depuis le 16 mai 2001 et s'il
vous plaît donnez nous aussi osama bin
laden qui est ce chef qui est tellement
proches de mollah omar et finalement
c'est terrible parce qu'on négocie avec
déformante fondamentalistes ont négocié
comment en négocierez avec finalement un
pays riche en leur promettant de leur
contre les concessions politiques eux
ils s'en fichent d'être à l'onu ce
qu'ils veulent c'est imposé l'émirat
islamique d'afghanistan et donc ont
négocié avec le diable et peut-être
perte or voilà les américains négocient
bien avant le 11 septembre 2001 avec
donc les talibans en leur disant c'est
soit un tapis d'or sur un tapis de
bombes c'est à dire en soi soit on vous
couvre d'or on vous laisse au
gouvernement on trouve une solution et
on fait passer notre 'pipeline' qu'il en
asie centrale soit robin bhar voilà
c'est la phrase c'est une phrase qui a
été prononcée par tom simons a donc été
le représentant de la diplomatie
américaine dans les dernières
négociations et ça ne manque pas de
piquant parce que après demain lundi se
déroulera à berlin
la première réunion de négociation qui
est sur l'afghanistan
et c'est précisément à berlin le 17
juillet qu'elles ont achoppé et que tom
simons a dit ce sera un tapis d'or ou un
tapis de bon voilà alors évidemment ces
négociations qui s
entamé par les américains avec les
talibans font que le gouvernement
américain relâche un peu la pression sur
la lutte antiterroriste et c'est
rassurant d'une certaine façon parce que
quand il ya eu l'histoire du world trade
center tout le monde s'est dit bon ils
sont pas très forts les services secrets
américains et quand on lit votre bouquin
on apprend qu'en fait ils ont un peu
relâché la pression et vous parlez d'un
type qui s'appelle john o'neill du fbi
qui a démissionné parce qu'ici il a dit
au gouvernement américain
vous vous occupez pas assez de la lutte
antiterroriste moi je démissionne
le drame de la faire c'est que ce john
o'neill est devenu responsable de la
sécurité pour le world trade center et
qu'il est mort ironie de l'histoire
ironie du sort il est mort le 11
septembre 2001 dans l'est dans les
ruines dans les cendres des wildcats et
c'est la conséquence logique hier et cet
aveuglement être à l'étranger
kid rock qui devient qui se retourne
contre nous qui devient un aveuglement
un terme finalement la diplomatie
américaine se dit on peut pas à la fois
s'accommoder de ces régimes et discuter
avec eux et puis effectivement laissé
faire des enquêteurs du fbi à y aller
dans ces différents pays pour mettre en
cause précisément ses réseaux et ses
pays et c'est pour ça qu effectivement
malheureusement le gouvernement
américains freine les enquêtes du fbi
aille mal a et saint john o'neill ces
négociations n'aboutissent pas à une
relation entre les américains les
talibans qui aurait donc régler le
problème du 'pipeline' n'aboutissent pas
et ben laden c'est que comme c'est pas
le tapis d'or savez ces tapis de bombes
donc il dit je vais frapper le premier
on dit aux talibans mon dieu talibans
leur montant américain en négociation le
dis clairement ou dali ben ouais et j'en
ai une frappe le premier le 11 septembre
en août les talibans sont acculés
effectivement là tout s'enchaîne et
c'est bien parce que les américains donc
la négociation des américains avec les
talibans d'achat commune à chaudes ben
laden fait 100 attentats du 11 septembre
et maintenant les américains ont de
bonnes raisons évidemment s'il allait
bombarder l'afghanistan tout en ouvre
les yeux voilà la tendance on leur rende
leur rôle et on peut imaginer qu'à
l'issue de ce qui se passe actuellement
s'il arrive à contrôler peu ou prou le
régime afghan
ils pourront construire ce fameux live
keira d'asie centrale
jusqu'à la mer et donc la cheminée en
occident donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on s'est tous fait avoir par la
propagande américaine
non non ça c'est ça c'est une opinion
ainsi que des personnages les produisent
en afrique et longe le admis mois le 11
septembre le 12 on nous a dit voilà
c'est terrible tout le monde avait l'air
très étonné tout ça quand on lit votre
bouquin et qu'on lui fait confiance en
tous les cas on se dit que finalement
voilà tout ça était pas si c'est bonnard
physis ali bongo fait pas surpris que ça
bien sûr on sait ce qui est terrifiant
mais quand on dit que c'est pas
uniquement il s'agit pas d'accuser les
américains d'abord c'est pas tous les
américains c'est des intérêts américains
qui ont pu jouer un rôle qui a eu des
conséquences gravissimes
mais tous les autres pays étaient
d'accord n'oubliez pas que on décrit
également la réaction du ministre
français des affaires étrangères hubert
védrine 17 juillet 2001 qui dit et donc
à l'issue de cette fameuse réunion de
berlin qui dit bon ben c'est vrai que ça
se passe ces négociations se déroulent
mal revenons voir le roi afghans et donc
c'est vrai que quand le 17 juillet en
voie de communiqué en ligne
de quel droit nous parle-t-on et
effectivement c'est après qu'on comprend
que donc les français et également aux
prises mais il les français comme les
britanniques comme d'autres suivez ces
négociations c'étaient les petits qui
suivait mais c'est le bloc
industrialisés qui avance avec ses
intérêts qui le principal financier de
ben laden on le sait aujourd'hui c'est
le numéro c'est le premier banquier
saoudien walid ben mahfouz il se trouve
que la libye n'a fusé connue des
américains depuis longtemps et surtout
du clan bush pourquoi parce qu'il a
permis à la famille bush au père et au
fils de monter leur affaire pétrolière
au texas il a financé à la fin des
années 70 et au milieu des années 80
alors que précisément le père était
président des états unis
c'est terrible voilà donc on est on est
au milieu de ce double jeu de ce double
langage mais qui est géré inc
conséquence logique de cette histoire on
a voulu on est aveuglé pendant tant
d'années
face à tous ces problèmes là
bergeron
dallas le raisonnement qui viennent vous
êtes retenu laisse supposer que ben
laden aurait préparé son attentat il ya
trois semaines avant le 20 septembre
or nous savons nous savons qu'un
attentat comme celui là il ya eu
d'autres investigations que les voûtes
qui ont été faites et qui indique qu'il
a fallu des mois peut être des années
pour former les kamikazes pour former
les formes et technologiquement les
formes et moralement mentalement c'est
le travail de très longue haleine
donc moi je pense en effet que la
diplomatie américaine soit immoral
qu'elle ait commis des erreurs les
occidentaux moi je suis le premier aldi
moi j'ai été le premier à protester
lorsque au mois d'avril ou mai dernier
chirac et jospin par exemple de manière
à mon avis déshonorante ont refusé de
recevoir le commandant massoud et ils
ont refusé de recevoir le commandant
massoud probablement parce qu'ils
avaient des bonnes raisons politiques
peut-être du genre de celles dont vous
parlez de le faire néanmoins je dis que
ça suffit pas parce qu'il faut pas non
plus faire l'impasse par exemple sur la
dimension fanatiques religieuses hors de
toute rationalité économique et
politique d'aidé de ben laden
je crois que quel que soit le lobby
pétrolier quelle que soit l'attitude de
bush ben laden est quelqu'un qui de
toute façon est animé par une espèce de
haine ni liste de l'occident
jean-charles on n'a pas voulu on a voulu
s'écarter précisément du chemin consiste
à faire une thèse ou formuler des
hypothèses sur cette situation qui est
très complexe précisé mme on a voulu se
documenter le plus possible avant de
parler avant d'écrire et c'est ce qu'on
a fait ce qu'on a fait et lorsque
effectivement on enquête sur ces réseaux
et qu'on voit bien qu'effectivement il
ya un mouvement si vous les circulaires
et que on retrouve on retrouve au centre
de ce cercle effectivement l'arabie
saoudite les intérêts pétroliers des
grands princes saoudiens qui sont au
coeur du financement de ben laden quand
même une cohérence à tous arc d'une
cohérence là leur explication c'est par
le pétrole de l'asie centrale qui est
quelque chose dont on nous parle pas
tous les jours et deux nuits
c'est à cet épisode j'en veux pour
preuve une déclaration conjointe de la
russie et d'iran il ya quelques jours en
pleine guerre lorsque alors que les
canons tonnent encore demandant la
convocation d'un sommet pétrolier dans
la caspienne sur trials temps on se
partageraient que d'un monde gâteaux et
les russes comment les russes là dedans
on s'apprête à matraquer des tchétchènes
pour l'instant qu'est ce que font les
russes réponse il s'apprête à matra
les tchétchènes ont terminé alors là
avec de l'ensemble avec un blanc sable
celui ça faisait partie du d'ailleurs de
soutien on vous soutient sur ben laden
et vous nous cassez pas les bonbons sur
la terreur les alors pour être plus
précis les rues st ces derniers jours
surtout financer le carburant des tadjik
pour qu'ils arrivent plus tôt dans
kaboom est donc pour inverser les plans
pas en tout cas pour chambouler les
plans de l'administration
essentiellement enfin l'américaine et
nonu sur la façon dont on allait gérer
l'après d'après d'aliments